hello and welcome to GS news for the
week of april fourteenth i'm your host a
hobo who lives under the sewers beneath
the GameSpot offices all the rest of our
staff are busy watching and re-watching
the last Jedi trailer or they're in the
studio making Star Wars sounds with
their mouths so you're stuck with me
sorry Nintendo had a whole host of
announcements this week which they
announced through their Nintendo Direct
presentation a format that they use so
that they can continue to ignore my
demands for a mother 3 localization the
rapid-fire presentation from Nintendo
this week dropped a lot of fast
approaching release dates here are some
of the highlights minecraft on switch
coming May eleventh the fast punching
arms on switch june sixteenth nintendo
shooter franchise splatoon july twenty
first new zelda amiibo modeled after
majora's mask Twilight Princess and
Skyward Sword on june 23rd cloud Corran
in Bayonetta amiibo July 21st and payday
2 for Nintendo switch coming sometime in
2017 didn't see that one coming have you
ever bought something and suffered
immediate regret while I may be stuck
with an industrial tub of jumbo cheese
balls Microsoft is going to be
introducing a way for you to return your
digital Xbox one and PC games the
reported feature is only part of the
Xbox insider program which Microsoft
uses to test out new features ahead of
their official launch but users of the
service have posted images detailing
what it involves on various gaming
forums you've spoken we've listened
reads the message in support of offering
gamers the freedom of choice we are
making changes to the Microsoft Store
purchases experience by offering
customers a simple way to instantly
return digital products like games and
apps through account microsoft com
according to another image games are
eligible for self-service refunds within
14 days of purchase if you have less
than two hours of playtime across all
accounts however DLC season passes and
add-ons are not eligible for
self-service refunds
star wars celebration is in full swing
this weekend but it looks like some
rebels may have intercepted the
battlefront to reveal trailer I'm sorry
the full battlefront 2 trailer was set
to reveal over the weekend during Star
Wars Celebration but someone got a
little excited and leaked it out early a
female soldier narrates the video which
shows there will be a story campaign
described as the untold soldier story as
well as multiplayer battles the series
is known for and as rumored battlefront
2 won't be limited to just one era of
Star Wars some of the characters shown
in the video include Darth Maul Yoda ray
and kylo Ren you may have a new mode of
traversal as well it looks like there
will be rideable tauntauns no details on
whether a scratch-and-sniff sticker will
also come with the game to let you fully
experience the pungent taunton aroma
speaking of leaks Blizzard also had a
pre-emptive trailer reveal this week
when overwatch uprisings trailer went
live a little bit early alongside new
skins items and sprays the update which
is out now introduces a new PvE mode
where you can team up with friends to
battle back hordes of a robotic onyx in
a press release for the mode Blizzard
said our latest seasonal event turns
back the clock giving you the chance to
relive a pivotal moment and overwatch
history explore the stories behind some
of your favorite heroes unlock pieces of
the past with over 100 to classified
loot box items or suit up with your
friends and join tracer on her very
first mission in a brand new competitive
wrong and finally I lost a bet on this
one the first images of the project
Scorpio dev kit have been revealed and
it turns out it's not just a cardboard
box full of scorpions while this
shouldn't necessarily be taken as an
indication of the final product the dev
kit which has been distributed to
developers for creating project Scorpio
games there is a strong resemblance to
the current xbox one Xbox boss Phil
Spencer also provided some additional
details about the system saying even
when you set Scorpio on top of your one
indirectly port maps like you literally
plug power in plug HDMI n it's all
exactly the same Spencer also offered a
reek
meant to VR running on the platform and
promised more details at e3 2017 and
that's your weekly news wrap-up I
promise next week you'll have an actual
good host and I'm going to get out of
here before the video producers find out
that I'm still pretending to work here
[Music]